the remains of Shinzo Abe were carried
into the venue by his widow akie
accompanied by the current prime
minister fumio kashida whose decision it
was to go ahead with this controversial
State funeral more than 4 000 guests
including many dignitaries and world
leaders they heard kashida lead tributes
to his friend and mental prime minister
Abe Westworth after all that you have
done for our nation and thank you most
sincerely may you rest in Eternal peace
are they served as prime minister twice
coming to power a second time as Japan
was recovering from the 2011 earthquake
and tsunami and that was really the
spirit that prime minister Abe did bring
to Japanese politics after the Fukushima
disaster yes Japan has got what it takes
to be a global Contender he was credited
with making Japan more assertive
internationally but his critics accuse
him of moving the country away from its
traditional path of pacifism and many
people have been protesting against this
event they've been angered by the cost
and Revelations since the assassination
about links with the unification church
or so-called Moonies have also hurt his
reputation and that of the current
government
still thousands turned out from all
parts of Japan to pay their respects
always stood up for his beliefs then
when many were against him
I like Abe very much I'm so happy to see
how many people have turned out
long lines waiting patiently to lay
flowers as their own tribute his legacy
will certainly be a controversial one
responsible for policies that were often
divisive here but Shinzo Abe seemed
determined to change Japan's position in
the world and he'll be remembered as one
of his country's most significant
political figures Rob McBride Al Jazeera
Tokyo